[Music]
in animal lawsuit news oh [ __ ] that's
Gary who's suing the cat submitted by
onions say Oh onion say oh that's funny
meaning it's uh hello in Korean onions
on sale on Jung ha say I'm Jung ha say
oh oh wait what's that phone that's
Korean from Korean then it's Korean
there's a movie where the kids named
onion wait how I don't know maybe it's a
crane movie are you high no it's from
something else
uh oh that's such a STONER thing yeah a
horse that was neglected by its owner is
now suing what awesome okay let's hear
the human element of this or maybe this
horse has a voice mr. head is suing I
know yeah so this horse's name used to
be shadow but now his name is justice
because shadow was its slave name hmm
he's three and he's coming back
yeah I know this poor horsey so he's an
eight year old horse American Quarter
Horse when they finally took him away
from the owner she was 300 pounds
underweight black coat was lice-ridden
Oh skin was scabbed and his genitals
were so frostbitten that they're still
considering amputation poor body this is
justice damn 300 pounds underweight Oh
beautiful yeah where's our [ __ ]
beautiful
oh damn look at his dad yeah it is big
his balls are sagging his dick prolapsed
so in the cold
it couldn't show that Govan protect
itself so it was exposed the whole time
it's another considering amputate that's
the first skinny horse I've ever seen
yeah usually buzzy bug that's all mine
it looks white because there's a boy
here he's never liked my gosh oh my
you starved a lot chai why would anyone
have a horse if they're just gonna leave
it in the [ __ ] snow the horses are
expensive I know there are a lot of
maintenance I don't know what that I
always hear anyone that's like into
horses or like it's a lot of hard work I
just know what that work is mm-hmm go to
brush them and feed them I think these
they like throughout the whole cuz
they're grazing animals so they eat
throughout the whole debate a [ __ ]
lot they need if we need to refill their
[ __ ] they need a lot of space to run
yeah and they're [ __ ] dumb too so you
have to watch watch out all the time our
friend has a horse and it's like a lot
cuz they'll eat anything even beans
that'll kill them they always have to
make sure I think I having a baby up to
make sure there's not weird food around
horse proofing yeah I got the horse
proofing
yeah so this horse is now suing his
former owner for negligence but who's
the person actually soon so it's mean
society the chicken lawyer that's
helping the horse out lawyer working for
Templeton animal legal defense
SPC it's the spider you have a spider -
ah - spider knows ha ha ha [ __ ]
writing a cease and desist or a [ __ ]
sue letter yeah serving yeah spider with
glasses is soon yeah and then [ __ ] a
pig is the lawyer yeah yeah just a
little boat IRA mm-hmm right he's like
I'm not just a pig you know and it's
like you know yeah so then what he's
thinking is at least $100,000 for
veterinary care as well as damages for
pain and suffering to fund a trust that
will stay with him no matter who his
caretaker is cuz that's right now he's
with like a special foundation or
they're trying to take care of him and
they're trying to find someone to adopt
him I mean he has like all these health
problems and so what like they're saying
like then it's really hard to get this
guy adopted because whoever adopts him
they're gonna be financially responsible
for all of these oh yeah thought
Maxwell's [ __ ] up I don't spend on
that money
decided to sue the former owner so then
that owner can be responsible for Elliot
also is it like the shelter that's suing
the former owner no it's it's like
Animal Legal Defense like some animal
foundation did the owner just go on a
long vacation and forget they don't go
into why but the owner did admit like
yeah I wasn't take Harry taking care of
him you could take this not a [ __ ]
house plant homie yeah Wow
they found out about about this this
neglected annum animal abuse thing here
because of the owners neighbor the
neighbor saw the for ratted amounts eat
sometimes nosy neighbors they're good
that's like the one time yeah I think
every other time I'm like leave everyone
alone I wish my neighbors would have
ratted on my pants and their be my ass
yeah thought of a nice but they didn't
and you're a better man now for I right
geo oh my god yeah right you yeah yeah
see yeah but then in if there's a horse
in this person's house it's probably
like a ranch or somewhere very far you
know so the neighbor has to go like yeah
I'm a big tree in like you got to go all
the way up in this [ __ ] ranch well
the horse if the horse is hungry they
probably don't have a lot of space or
they're walking up along the edges
trying to find food and chips yeah they
keep them in a state what don't even
have to be that nosy yeah yeah it's a
big [ __ ] horse yeah but then this
just brings up a lot of debate of like
alright well where are we gonna draw the
line for animals to be considered legal
persons because corporations and I
believe ships can be considered as legal
person so they have certain rights ships
yeah corporations and ships that term
can be applied to corporations and ships
is because back in a day when rich
people got together and funded like a
ship to go in the spice trade or get
gold or whatever that was the beginning
of forming a corporation and then they
don't have any liability fellowship yeah
they don't they don't want a liability
for something that happens in a storm or
whatever they paid for this ship to go
out and they don't want to get in
trouble something like that yeah so then
now they're just saying that's why ships
back in it did the guy get any other
legal charges be
cuz of animal abuse basically that I'm
okay with yeah well it is a federal like
crime yeah yeah now for animal abuse in
Oregon and all 50 states
what about like just killing a chicken
and then eating it and having trouble
think that's animal abuse though okay
yeah negligence abuse yeah if you were
like beating the chicken everyday--
yeah okay if you're choking within it
yeah that's abusive well you're about to
choke the chicken once a day at least
oh that's it well this more than once
then it to be the abuse to be born like
this
my dick is suing me for them before I
only want the farm you know they don't
want to take care well you wanna you
want to sanctuary I have lots of be on
the farm where I want one but I want to
do any other caring yeah that's what I
said I don't even there's no part of my
brain I don't think anything else it's
just therapeutic have you ever had a
farm no but I've like helped out and I
don't want to shovel like pink [ __ ] all
day or like well it depends on what your
crop is or what you farm or my uncle
farm emus yeah it's an interesting
livestock yeah and it's not a profitable
one either what does that mean like does
he breathe them and like me would he
just bought a [ __ ] any emus and then
they would have sex with each other and
make babies and then he would try to
sell the eggs but not really he would
try to sell what's called emu oil which
is like from their feathers and he said
oh you can use it for the arthritis you
can use it for L&T really any goddamn
thing you can think of and nobody would
ever buy it and then he just sort of had
this emu ranch and never made money off
of it and whenever you went there it was
so funny we were all there and when he
drove up the Hughes would run along with
your cars was like [ __ ] Jurassic Park
these prehistoric birds are like [ __ ]
eleven or seven and eight feet tall and
they're like like running along with
your vehicle that's dough time we're all
there and my little brother he was
probably like I don't know seven years
old at the time we're like we're not
[ __ ] Kenny go and we look and on top
of a rock my little brother's on top of
a rocket he's lonely
mmm and they're all surrounded
Oh me dude it reminds me of that movie
dude where's my car
remember when they end up at the guy
that guy's house they were gonna locked
up in that guy's house because he thinks
they're EMU poachers
and the emo like knocks the guy's head
did that mean ambitious they are mean
yeah they're really and they love shiny
things so I had a watch on and I didn't
really know that watch on you didn't
know you know I wasn't think you just
didn't think that because you have to be
supposed to take all shiny things off oh
your eyeballs I heard that they pick at
your eyeballs they try to pick for
whatever the [ __ ] yeah they're mean
they're benas [ __ ] so one of them picked
he was going for my watch but he got me
in the arm and it [ __ ] hurt like
crazy so I don't like automatic reaction
I just [ __ ] socked him in the face I
didn't know what to do and then he goes
like like this [ __ ] but I didn't try to
like up these and I was just like you
know [ __ ] self-defense yeah bird
watch the EMU in a head I don't give a
[ __ ]
aníbal look like an abuse should be fine
for sure
but did you hear about fizzle and it's
kind of ridiculous though so the guy
were the monkey sued him because of the
selfie oh yeah I love you mentioned in
the here's Eve that is like that Street
that crosses the line for me because
that's not like any abuse or any neglect
or anything like that and monkeys don't
profit from things or making businesses
or what you don't think animals can be
humans they can't be persons now you
just said you just answered your own
question know what this person this
person saying the horse could be a
person in a lawsuit yeah they're suing
as a person I don't you don't think
humans can be animal I don't think so no
well they're calling it a person and I
personally believe that vegetables calls
me persons that a person or an entity
they call it legal person yeah that
you're suing either way do you mean that
human vegetables can be no I think a
moldy orange to be able to sue the
supermarket for hey why am I so maybe my
human vegetable do you mean someone
that's in a cult and like catatonic
state yeah I thought that's what he was
saying he's talking about bok choy yeah
bok choy with black dots on it concern
on land
but yeah it's a slippery slope yeah when
do you put it in I don't think that they
should be able to sue as legal persons
but I do think that the previous owners
should be find a bunch or have some sort
of repercussion that helps pay for the
animals case you don't know what the
animal wants and thinks right so you
can't how can you represent something
that doesn't know what you just said
know that what that argument though
they're saying like well there's kids
that are being represented they don't
know what happened to them but they're
victims
those are people you think yeah but
they're using that same that's a good
you know no I don't think it's a good
point because the people end up growing
up and being psychologically damaged
like that that has actual repercussions
because they have to go and be a members
of society and you're [ __ ] with their
mental is like a horse is never gonna
grow up to talk yeah what about like
mentally disabled people that can't even
speak or or express themselves but
they're also victims that's true because
gorillas could probably express
themselves better than some of them yeah
yeah ee I don't want the Apple yeah
[Music]